alors quand on examine les
caractéristiques de chacune des planètes
on peut commencer par mercure parce que
c'est la planète la plus proche la plus
proche du soleil
on peut toujours s'interroger quel est
l'intérêt scientifique de chacune de ces
planètes chacune évidemment présente un
intérêt spécifique puisque chacune a des
caractéristiques particulières en ce qui
concerne le mercure est mise à part la
caractéristique d'être plus proche du
soleil mais ça lui confère justement des
propriétés des propriétés particulières
il fait très très chaud assure mercure
d'un côté et de l'autre côté il fait
très froid
pourquoi c'est extraordinaire parce que
devront mercure gravitas je prends 55
millions de km du soleil les lois de 2
qui combine la rotation propre des
planètes sur elles mêmes et leur
révolution c'est-à-dire leur parcours
orbitales autour du soleil ne disent que
dans certains cas de figure c'est
valable pour le couple soleil mercure il
ya une synchronisation des orbites c'est
à dire que finalement la période de
rotation va s'accorder avec la période
de révolution
[Musique]
une face et éclairées en permanence par
le soleil effet 500 degrés mais ça veut
dire que l'autre fasse elle est
perpétuellement dans l'obscurité et sur
l'autre face il doit faire aussi par
mois - -150 degrés moins 200 degrés
alors vous imaginez la limite la
transition entre le jour et la nuit
[Musique]
n'oublions pas par exemple
historiquement mercure est là une
planète qui a permis de faire l'une des
premières vérifications expérimental de
la fameuse théorie de la relativité
générale à vincennes avait proposé à
1915 puisque mercurey temps très proche
du soleil et le plus soumise ces effets
gravitationnels et on avait observé
depuis longtemps déjà
une anomalie dans son orbite
c'est-à-dire l'orbité de mercure une
orbite elliptique décrite normalement
par les lois de kepler avancée très
légèrement son petit qu'on appelle son
grand dax avançait très légèrement au
cours du temps on appelle ça la la
précession de l'orbité elec la bonne
explication a été trouvé c'est la
théorie de la relativité générale
d'einstein la faible courbure de
l'espace en primé par le soleil au
niveau de la planète mercure qui
explique que ça donc ça a permis de
tester les a été l'un des premiers tests
de la théorie de la relativité générale
[Musique]
il y a certain nombre de missions
spatiales actuellement prévu il y en
cours de route vers mercure pourra
explorer plus en détail les les
propriétés je veux voir aussi que
mercure d'une certaine façon ça
ressemble en tout cas sa surface est
entièrement cratérisée donc ça ressemble
à la lune tout simplement parce que des
bruits dans nos sphères leur soit
directement les impacts des innombrables
corps qui vagabondent système solaire
des petits astéroïdes les météorites et
caetera et donc l'étude de la
caractérisation de mercure nous apprend
beaucoup de choses sur justement la
circulation des corps des objets
vagabond dans le système solaire
[Musique]